the hardest respect to earn is one's own  how do you actually do the stuff that  creates the wealth the empire the status  all that stuff there's three elements to  the the goal you have the external  result which might be make more money  get a six-pack whatever you've got the  processes behaviors activity that result  in that goal like doing the work the  third aspect is being the type of person  who does those things so basically  identifying  with those types of behaviors or being  the type of person who does those types  of activities which then creates the  reward what would a person who does this  type of thing do in this instance what  would a wise man do what would a  billionaire do when you ask that  question is who you will eventually  become as you continue to cast votes  that reinforce the stories that we tell  ourselves about who we are and those are  the things that create long lasting deep  change